[Music]
what kind of plastics can be recycled
polyethylene terephthalate high density
polyethylene polyvinyl chloride
low-density polyethylene polypropylene
and polystyrene see the fourth one again
low-density polyethylene wrong it's low
density polyethylene Maura please
identify these extremely rare animals
that's a Pangolin that's a black spotted
khuskhus a northern hairy-nosed wombat
elephant shrew an okapi nope
it's a sigh Ola no-name this animal how
did the Democratic presidential
candidate who's the current mayor of
South Bend Indiana pronounce his name
Pete Buddha judge thanks it's been
driving me crazy little fool what does
scuba stand for self-contained
underwater breathing apparatus
what does lazer stand for light
amplification by stimulated emission of
radiation and what about Taser Thomas a
swift electric rifle and what about IKEA
Ingvar Kamprad
Elm tread guna read its the founders
initials in his home town in Sweden okay
which Dutch architect am I thinking of
right now eyes at REM koolhaas
yes
fail to process more